alright so my name is Lauren Merriman um
I'm a senior right now I'm actually
graduating in February I took this class
because I decided I really wanted to
make video games and this is a good
class to take my team is seven people
and we're mostly seniors we made a game
about collar the other team focused on
the the younger 8 to 13 and we focused
on a little bit older about 13 and above
so we could have a little bit
complicated more complicated mechanics
and texts where we needed it so that we
didn't really have to rely on figuring
out how to make everything really easy
to read so you know it uses English that
assume someone who speaks English could
read and understand very easily in our
games a strategy game it's it's real
time where you know the days are cut
like you have to survive a year and the
days are automatic so you have to go and
take care of four different localities
and give them either soap or water
containers or electrolytes to help heal
them and later on you get boiling water
and you just have to you know take care
of these for localities for a year
so we learned you know early on in the
class you start by your first project is
just paper prototype and then after you
have to make digital prototypes but they
usually expect you to have paper
prototype and for this one they expected
you to do you know however you wanted to
and so we started off with a paper
prototype and we sort of then quickly
implemented it digitally because there
were certain things that doing it with
paper would take a long time to sort of
make a calculation but we originally had
like part of it was you could see on the
screen what the localities where they
were and then you would try to implement
things but we didn't like have a screen
to help you select that and so we would
sort of like you tell us what you pick
and then we quickly put it in the game
and reset it so that's why we were
gently didn't it was really hard to do
it that way because people like going
from the screen to a paper prototype
they were confused and then really see
how things interacted so then we sort of
our next big thing was make it all
digital and in the presentation that you
saw you know we had that original shot
of the what the game looked like one we
had it all digital and it was just like
a really poorly designed GUI and it was
hard to read and hard to understand and
people were really struggling with it so
I actually was the one who redesigns the
GUI and then it went through a couple
iterations with the new GUI so we
decided how to make it the most clear
and I mostly I sat down and I looked at
other strategy games mostly civilization
it's actually not a big strategy like
game player so I actually had to go like
look around see what other places do and
I stole a little bit from civilization
and a few other games that just had good
elements of design that looked clear and
understandable even to someone who's
never touched the game before and so
that's what i wanted in our game so
that's why we implemented it the way we
did and yeah then the game kind of
turned into the way it is now
so one of the biggest things is I'm not
a programmer so I was doing either
design or product management or you know
the scrum master is what they call it
which is someone who's sort of has to
like take care of the team and make
everything fit together whether it's
with like including art and music and
coding making sure all those elements
fit together into one cohesive whole and
so that's sort of the role that I
started to do and then really liked
doing at first i thought you know on
some of these projects i should take on
a coding role to try to force myself to
learn but i felt like i realized i
didn't really want to I really liked
doing this role instead but you learn
that it's really hard especially in a
class setting where people aren't really
tied like monetarily to this class you
can't lose your job if you don't do your
job you can do poorly in the class but
because it's a group thing you know you
might not do that poorly because the
group presented like this is our game
and so unless you specifically call out
that person they're still going to get
credit for it and so it was really
difficult as the product manager to get
people to do what they said they were
going to do in a timely manner and get
people to respond to my emails and so it
was really something that you have to
get people to understand especially
towards the end where we didn't have a
lot done and we needed to change a lot
that you know there's not a lot of time
and there's still a lot to do and then
when I finally got everyone in a meeting
and they all sat down and we talked
about this like everyone you just heard
it like oh that's when that's do so you
know it finally got people in gear and
so I wish I could have done this earlier
in the semester with just this project
with the other project that was it
people in Rio's we fall into that trap
as much because we've only two weeks so
you know two weeks doesn't give you a
lot of time to fail you got to do it
quickly and but when it was eight weeks
it was a lot of time as people are like
oh we can push this off a little further
like it was really hard i actually ended
up having um I talked to the professor's
to try to figure out a way to get my
team to listen to me and it was still
really hard but once you finally get
everyone together and really lay it out
very clearly I like the clarity is what
I was missing I thought I was being very
like clear and like this is how things
would do and even with the way I was
assigning tasks I thought I was being
very clear and I wasn't I was really
missing concrete details I said you know
guys like implement this idea like
implement that you can like take the
actions but I didn't tell them this is
how it should look this is how it should
feel and so when it got implemented it
wasn't when I thought it was I'm like
this is really disappointing is really
ugly so when I sat down and redid it and
then told them exactly what I expected
things got done faster because it like
like we said in our presentation people
weren't really motivated for this game
and so having the motivation and really
vague instructions made it that people
wouldn't do it until like you know you
put that off like that's a really hard
task I need to figure out what she
expects and then I need to do it and I
don't really want to so that's something
you put off to the end and so when you
give people clearer instructions it
makes it easier just to do it because
they're like oh like that's simple i can
do that really quickly and so I think
that was the easiest ways when you
really set clear instructions clear
deadlines and you can't really punish
people there's no way of slapping them
on the wrist when they don't do it but
you can just not assign them work and
you move it to somebody else and
eventually people realize that they
weren't getting assigned any work and
they realize like hey I'm not actually
doing anything for this can I have work
and way said you know you have to do it
by this time and if you don't then you
know we're pretty screwed so really
doing that really making sure you clear
deadlines and shifting the work around
so that people who will do the work and
can do the work and have the time to do
work are getting the work and the people
who either just are doing the work or
maybe don't have the time that week
because that also happens where like one
week will be really tough so you move
shift will work away from them so you
have to be better about I think I if I
started being better about how I gave us
work rather than just you know evenly
dividing it that really would help with
the project
so working with the client was hard
because he was unavailable a lot and you
know his he he the times he did come to
class he said you know if you have to
email me a question it better be really
clear concise her like we're not going
to answer it and so luckily in the
beginning we kind of knew what we wanted
to do with our game and so we just kind
of went in that direction and then
whenever Pablo came into class Pablo was
our main client we also had Ellie but
she was only in class a couple times and
so we didn't get as much feedback from
her so whenever Pablo came into class he
told us what we needed to fix and that
was the biggest the biggest interaction
with him that we had it was really I
first wouldn't really know who to design
it for because they said you know we
needed a call or we need to call our
games for everybody so we were really
unsure and so finally like three or four
weeks into the project we sat down we
talked to the other caller team and said
what are you doing because we're going
to do the opposite so because they
wanted two games that would be four
different groups and so then we did that
we talked to Pablo the next time he came
in and he said yes this is what i want
so luckily we managed to guess what he
wanted it could have gone worse if we
did something that he didn't wanted so
if that had happened and he said you
know you guys are really going in the
wrong direction I think we would have
liked made sure to email him more but
most of the time he's like I like the
direction you're going you just need to
fix these sorts of things that's so
that's what we did